a migrant rescue ship that's repeatedly
found itself blocked from docking in
European ports as once again resumed its
mission to rescue people off the coast
of Libya
however the Italian Interior Minister
has already warned it won't be allowed
to return to any Italian port the
Aquarius is a rescue ship operated by
the franco-german charity SOS
méditerranée and Doctors Without Borders
it has a capacity to carry up to 500
migrants who were picked up trying to
make the perilous crossing from Libya to
Italy in June both Italy and Malta
refused to allow the ship to dock which
at the time had more than 600 packs on
board
Borneo rafinha whispered I want to put
an end to this human trafficking which
puts thousands of lives at risk so in
the same way that will raise the issue
for the Aquarius we will raise it for
all other vessels that follow Messiah
salvini strong anti immigration policy
provoked a clash over the immigration
issue with Luxembourg's Minister for
Foreign Affairs Jean ISIL born during a
EU meeting in Vienna
[Music]
Lupe Google's or fall
or the rise of the anti-migrant
Euroskeptic Matteo salvini has now seen
him make the front cover of the latest
Time magazine it brands the politician
Italy's immigration saw and claims he's
now the most feared man in Europe
political analyst Nicola Merkava CH
believes EU citizens no longer trust
old-school politicians situation and
Italy is difficult situation in Italy
with the migrants but also with the
economy is not good Matteo Cellini was
elected by the Italian people for
different reasons and so far he is
extremely popular I think matter Cellini
is delivering what he promised so then
we can agree or disagree on what he is
delivering but in any case he definitely
is delivering on his campaign and I
think this is a lot of something a lot
of people are expecting is that when the
politician the politicians come into
power that they do what they promised
people want to see in Europe people
delivering on fundamental questions and
these fundamental questions across the
political spectrum are unemployment
migration security and they want to see
politicians who are going to bring
immediate answers to those questions
because more and more Europeans do not
trust the old school of politicians and
more and more now today are trusting the
new school as material Slovenia is one
of the representative
you